in this dystopian world
your resistance group is humanity's last
hope
unfortunately you've all been captured
by the tyrannical rulers
and brought to the ancient coliseum for
their deadly entertainment
before you're thrown into the dungeon
you see many numbered hallways leading
outside
but each exit is blocked by an electric
barrier
with a combination keypad you learn that
one of you
will be allowed to try to escape by
passing a challenge
while everyone else will be fed to the
mutant salamanders the next morning
with her perfect logical reasoning zara
is the obvious choice
you hand her a concealed audio
transmitter so that the rest of you can
listen along
as zara is led away you hear her
footsteps echo through one of the
hallways
then stop a voice announces that she
must enter a code
consisting of three positive whole
numbers in ascending order
so the second number is greater than or
equal to the first
and the third is greater than or equal
to the second
she may ask for up to three clues but if
she makes a wrong guess
or says anything else she'll be thrown
back into the dungeon
for the first clue the voice says the
product of the three numbers
is 36. when zara
asks for the second clue it tells her
the sum of the numbers
is the same as the number of the hallway
she
entered there's a long silence
you're sure zara remembers the hallway
number but there's no way for you to
know it
and she can't say it out loud
if zara could enter the passcode at this
point she would
but instead she asks for the third clue
and the voice announces that the largest
number
appears only once in the combination
moments later the buzz of the electric
barrier
stops for a few seconds and you realize
that zara has escaped
unfortunately her transmitter is no
longer in range
so that's all the information you get
can you find the solution
you're worried about the fact that you
don't know zara's hallway number
but you decide to start from the
beginning anyways
from the first clue you work out all of
the eight possible combinations
that come out to a product of 36 one of
these must be right
but which one now comes the hard part
even though you don't know which number
you're looking for you decide to work
out the sum
of each combination's three numbers
that's when it hits you all but two of
the sums are unique
and if the hallway number had matched
any of these zara would have known the
correct combination
right then and there without asking for
the third clue
since she did ask for the clue the
hallway number must have matched the
only sum
that appears more than once in the list
but which of the two combinations that
add up to 13
is correct 166 or 229
that's where the third clue comes in
since it tells us that the largest
number must be unique
229 must be the code when night falls
you and the others escape through
hallway 13 and rejoin
zara outside you've freed yourselves
through math and logic
now it's time to free the rest of the
world
hi everybody if you liked this riddle
try solving these two
you